this is a there's an erudite question
rattling off mission names and things in
Carolyn Porco who she mentioned is a
colleague of mine a scientist a
planetary scientist who doesn't work on
the nearby planets doesn't work on
Mercury or Mars Mars has been in all the
news yeah these past months she works on
Saturn which happens to be my favorite
planet it's also her favorite plant was
it your favorite planet it's so obvious
what do I even have to say I think if
you're gonna pick a favorite planet all
the other planets are clearly jealous so
the best point the Rings because that's
where in the new Star Trek they head to
behind the Rings that was so that's
pretty real about them yeah we hid
behind the Rings by the way these rings
are basically you know they're like
they're very thin you know any radio
signal which just passed through it
presumably these spaceships in the
future some other ways of seeing other
than visible light so I just be hide
behind Saturn's rings I can't go there
but the concern is that we okay concern
the concern is that we are we are
focusing too much perhaps NASA is
focusing too much on nearby planets when
there's all the glory of the outer solar
system waiting for us to tap and well
she didn't say it she quote she did say
that also we have no manned mission
scheduled over the next 10 15 years
yes so is nasa being short-sighted the
answer is NASA is being underfunded yeah
NASA isn't short-sighted they would love
to do all this stuff right Saul they do
exactly and as I said that with the
previous question the balance of whether
you study something on the inner solar
system versus the outer solar system is
not always what is most interesting is
what is most doable and what is most
doable in people's lifetimes I mean is
possibly so you know just get a fatter
engine to me yet to get it out there so
my point is it's a complex matrix
decision matrix that the planetary
scientists use and but apart from that
NASA is simply underfunded to not only
do all the science we wanted to do not
only do all the
the crude missions on a timescale that
will keep us Punk'd yeah but also NASA
has been charged with beat monitoring
earth and doing other sort of what
people might consider practical things
like monitoring weather and climate
change and all the rest of this and the
environment and so if you want NASA to
do all of the above
you have funded at the level of all of
you but what uh is there something that
you think that would be a simple thing
that people could do to try to get NASA
more funding or no yeah vote out of
office the people who don't fund that's
it it's that simple this is a democracy
let's make it work for us but I wrote a
whole book on it I mean essentially it's
called space chronicles racing the
ultimate frontier and in the I type just
talk about ways to to rethink the role
of NASA and space exploration as a
driver of all that we care about in a
modern society our economy wealth or
dreams or visions
you know everything that drove us that
got us out of the 60s and still enabled
us to hope yeah and to dream about a
future that we might make for ourselves
we have just 10 seconds seconds look